foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well in that case what are we drinking
same for the goddaughter God told me you
found something
on a train during a war a dial that
could change the course of history why
are you chasing the thing that drove
your father crazy
don't move please get out of here
sorry
Dr Jones get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
foreign
[Music]
and now a final Triumph
give them hell Indiana Jones
a few times in my life we've seen things
or the torture with voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
and I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]